Badass motherfucker! What's up guys. Good to be here. Rocking the
mic like a badass MF.
You guys didn't have the intellectual energy to keep up with that joke. I feel bad for you.
Why are you so dumb? Try to like. Try harder. Think. Think more. Why aren't you thinking?
My sister's such a bitch man.
I have a thing in my nose. Is that what's distracting you
from my comedy. Or are you guys just thinking about yourselves as always. So selfish.
You guys think about me and my career for once.
Just imagine you're an Asian child. Isn't that fun? Aren't you tired of being yourselves
Don't you want to relief from always
being you all the time
Goddamn Americans. Me me me. That's all you are.
Is yourselves. You can't be other people
that's why you bomb them. Anyways it was fun to talk
in front of your faces. Have a good day.